MATTHIEU MAYRAN: Hi, everyone.
My name is Matthieu Mayran.
I work as a Solution
architect for Google.
And today we're going
to see how Airbus
scales workers and workers for
processing satellite images.
I am today with Laurent
Gabet the Optical R&D manager
for Airbus.
And we are going to
switch to present you
all those slides
and do some demos.
So Laurent is going to
start by introducing
a little bit about how Airbus
decided to move to the cloud,
show you a couple of like
workflows for image processing.
Then I will take over
to actually explain
a few concept of compute engine
and Google Cloud platform.
And then discuss
where it will be--
what kind of implementations
were done by Airbus.
And then we will talk about
next step for Airbus and also
for you if you want to get
started on Google Cloud.
So for now Laurent's
going to get started.
LAURENT GABET: OK.
Hello everybody.
Good afternoon.
So I'm glad to be here with you
in this impressive Google Cloud
event.
So I will provide you today,
during this one hour testimony
of how we've begin Airbus
Defence and Intelligence.
We moved from our prem facility
to a public cloud facility.
So you will discover that it
has been a quite challenging
experience for us.
So we will not start by
that, but if you stay with us
during this hour normally,
thanks to all the details
that the Matthieu
will provide you,
you be able to implement
such a workflow by yourself.
So, please, stay in the room.
OK.
So first before
starting, in order
to understand the
presentation, you
should know who is Airbus
Defense and Space Intelligence.
It's a business unit of
Airbus, the well known brand.
I guess that you already
flew with an Airbus aircraft.
So we have four
pillars in our activity
two ones on the left:
satellite imagery
and solution and services based
on those satellite imagery.
So we will dig
this subject today.
And two other subject focusing
on the defense applications.
So intelligence, so
AI, as we have seen,
is a key issue for this
topic, and a mission,
a complex personal mission
planning for defense.
So lets start the presentation.
So here we have our own
satellite earth observation,
the satellite constellation.
So we have today in the air
seven satellites, five of them
are optical and two
of them are radar.
So the two main flagships
in this constellation
are the SPOT satellites and
the Pleiades satellites.
And the two radar satellite that
you see here on the right are
quite well known because we
built the mapping in 3D of all
the earth, in once we've--
those interferometric engines.
So it provides the best and
more accurate 3D mapping
of the earth.
So lets start from
a long time ago.
So 30 years ago, we launched
our first satellites,
which was Spot One.
And it was the first
civilian satellites
with the telescopic
capabilities.
so enabling the 3D capacity.
So since all of our
satellites are able to provide
the 3D processing
of the earth, which
is quite important nowadays
because 3D is a key feature.
So 30 years ago we were already
digital, as you can see.
Some of you may
remember this time,
but most of the
people in this room
are younger than 30 years old,
so they have not noticed that.
You may see that we were
already fashioned by the time,
wearing a beard.
And we were doing our best
to satisfy our customer
and having a map of the earth
and planning the satellite's
shape on the earth.
So that was quite
challenging by the time.
We were not yet object storage.
So putting an image
in the object storage
was not as efficient.
So here it was tape.
So we had to remove
the tape to put back
the tape to get the image, etc.
So it was interesting, but
everything was digital.
And at this time we
were very proud of that.
Our main competitor by that
time was a Russian company,
a Russian satellite, and
they were analog satellite.
So it was-- we were
very proud of that.
It was taking days
and weeks and weeks
to get an image,
and even the image,
the sensor were digital but
the key issue by that time
was to get to the
customers a good printing
shot of those images
on a very strong paper.
Because most of our customers
were not digital by the time,
they were analog,
and those images
where we are pushed on
their analog stereoplotter
in order to do their mapping.
OK.
We improved days,
years after years,
and now we are providing
in a digital form
to our customer digital
imagery, nice ones.
We have nice colors,
as you can see.
It was hours, I
say in the past it
was because now we
are on the Cloud
so we are not hours anymore.
But it's still the same images.
OK.
So we move to the
Cloud, and I will
describe what it means for
us to move in the cloud,
to the cloud, but for us
it has been a major step
to work efficiently.
So here we have--
now we are able--
now whole of our
images on the cloud.
And we are able to
access them within a time
frame of half a second.
We can have unlimited
users, the platform
can host an unlimited
number of images.
It's worldwide.
This morning Eric Schmidt
said that the good thing
with the Google Network is
that you can access the data
everywhere in the world.
And it's really true
it's really true for us.
We are using this
functionality and our customers
are very well served.
Today we are storing
a part of our images,
we are not at a full power
because we are looking,
we are waiting a little bit to
see how things are going on.
So it's off of our capacities,
of our satellite capacities.
And it represent half a
petabyte per year, roughly.
We are currently
producing, developing,
building our next
constellation satellites,
which will be far more
accurate, far more precise.
We have a far more--
of a larger efficiency.
And we will be at a resume
of two petabyte a year.
So our satellites are
fully, directly connected
to the cloud, and we
are feeding the cloud
at a resume of 2 million of
square kilometers per week.
So it's represented at
roughly four times the surface
of Spain.
per week.
So few words about the process.
So before deciding
to go to the cloud,
we had to pick the
right client for us.
So we went through an RFP.
So we are in an Airbus company.
I mean, you have
to go such things.
And so it was seven
the cloud providers
provided their feedback.
And obviously we pick
Google for the many reasons.
I could highlight some of them.
First one there was a
commitment of Google
that they will support us
bringing to life our system
and being successful.
They did it.
I have to admit that
they have been very, very
efficient doing that.
And the best is that we
are presenting together
with Matthieu.
Matthieu help us a lot
during this process.
Another point is security.
As we have all
heard this morning
with HSBC and the others
going to the cloud security
is a major issue.
So Google do have the right
features for this, for us.
And other point is
about the roadmap.
In their roadmap
there was-- we were
very interested by a
high machine learning.
So it was already disclosed
when we sign or contract,
because for us a high machine
learning is very crucial
in order to extract
automatically
information from our images.
So we pick Google and we
start implementing our system
on the cloud platform.
So the first step was about
to connect our satellites
to the cloud.
So we have been
around the Earth,
and we have our satellites
flying over them.
And when they have images,
they are just uploading,
downloading those images.
And we develop internally
all the connections in order
to have a fully automatic
process from the satellite
up to where we call it
the Intelligence Digital
Platform on the cloud Platform.
So we uploaded all of our
images on the object storage.
And when we do that
at the same time
we need to do some
processing in order
to prepare them to be easily
accessible and rapidly
accessible to J reference
them, to adjust them in order
to be fully cartographic.
So this is done in the
cloud infrastructure.
Then last year, end of
September last year,
based on the platform, we
opened our first service,
which is One Atlas.
So you are welcome to
subscribe to it for a fee,
it's not it's not free.
But we open the first
service, so it gives access
to our catalog of
data and images,
which are just sitting
there, to be used.
I will provide you
a real time demo
just right after this slide.
And we are working
and we have already
developed new
services, solution,
fully developed native cloud.
So we went through the
process that Eric Schmidt
described this morning.
I mean, the first [INAUDIBLE]
steps is you can take your code
and you put your code, you are
30 years old code or whatever,
and you put your code
as it is on the VM.
You can do that.
But when you are
doing that, especially
for a remote sensing
image processing,
you are not using the best of
the elasticity and capacity
of the cloud.
So we had to redevelop not
most but part of our processing
in order to have a [INAUDIBLE]
less processings, processes,
and in order to use fully
the elasticity of the cloud.
So we have developed that,
and we have a few solution.
And I will introduce, just
after the first walk through,
the workflow that we
implemented in order
to do a very
high-end processing.
So certainly also
on the analytics
we are working now on AI.
As it has been
introduced this morning,
we are using a TensorFlow.
So we put it by ourself
or we are using now ML.
And we have the ability
today automatically
to extract all the
clouds which are
in the images, the
planes which are
in the images, a
key subject for us.
And we are starting, I
mean, a few other subjects
which are quite confidential
for the time being.
Few words about how
an industrial company
such as Airbus, the
difficulty to go to the cloud,
to the public cloud.
And similar that in 3 point.
So security, we already
are ready to describe
that a little bit.
So this morning HSBC, say
I was quite impressed.
Because they say
that in six months
they were on the public cloud.
And, in fact, for us it
took us six months just
to do the paperwork and to get
the stamp and the clearance
from our security team
because it's our first attempt
to go to the public cloud.
So now it will be
faster, certainly.
So this process basically
took us around one year.
So another key point for us
a standard industry company
is the cloud technologies.
So we have very talented
engineer in the company.
They are able to fly
rockets, to build satellites,
to create optics, whatever.
But the technology
are not yet there.
And it can go very fast,
but it's not sitting there.
So we have to go
step by step in order
to increase the team which
do have the knowledge.
And also it's so fast.
And that can be an
issue, and we don't
know how we will deal
with that in the future.
But it's so fast
that as soon as you
have done something in
a way it's already old
and there is something new.
And so what I will
describe today
it's something that
we did six months ago,
but we are already working
on the next step, which
is using a queue when it
has the contenders and not
the VM anymore.
So we are already changing
our way to do things.
So it's kind of a difficulty
for an industrial company.
And the other point is our
goal is to be in operation.
And so I don't know who said
that this morning, but it's
very, very difficult for
a company like us which
is used to do something
that should be right
and there is no failure,
like an aircraft,
to a world where you should
be prepared for any failure
and react.
So it's a different mindset.
And our operation
team, which makes sure
that everything is
working 24 hours by seven
has to get used to that and has
to be prepared and all of that.
So that's another difficulty
for us is to move to operation.
So let's go to the demo.
OK.
So that's our product.
So it's One Atlas.
So here we have just
a small page in order
to introduce our data sets.
So you can go in
anywhere in the world.
So you can go in Asia,
in Australia by example.
And you can zoom in, and
you will see that all.
Step by step you will see
the details of all the images
that are there.
So here you see
the set of images
and when you zoom in you can
see all the pile of images.
So here we have
a kind of mosaic,
but in fact it's the latest
images that are visible.
And an image is showing up every
three minutes in the cloud.
And this is updating this
mosaic every three minutes.
So let's go to San
Francisco my example.
I don't know why.
OK.
Now it's San Jose, so
San Jose is not that.
Let's try to see
the [INAUDIBLE].
OK.
OK, here we go.
So it goes to San Francisco.
So you can see that
it's quite fast.
The access to those images
is done for the B2B markets.
So the customers, which
are buying a subscription
are using those images in
order to do mapping activities,
cartography activities.
And they are
plugging those images
in their own
cartographic engines.
So a user which is in India
or wherever it should not
wait for more than one second
to get the imagery in order not
to slow down it's job.
So where is the most current?
So the most current
is somewhere.
Yeah, I think that's the one.
So you can zoom
in, and you can see
the most current which is here.
So you can turn it
around, and on this spot
if I zoom out on San Francisco.
What you have here
are all the images.
What you see here are
all the images which
are available on this area.
So we can see that we have a
set of play ads of May 1st.
Then we have a play ad of April.
So March 16, September, June.
OK, so all of those images which
are acquired by the satellites
are occupied in the catalog,
and we are introducing
for an easy access this mosaic.
So if we can go--
from one key feature is if we
see those images are prepared
by our systems, so that they
are fully aligned in order for--
so you can see that there is
two different images here.
But they are fully aligned in
our internal processing engine
in order to make sure that
the cartographer, which
are using them, are
using them properly
and provide accurate results.
So what OUR customers are using
it's certainly not this tool.
It's the URL.
In fact all the
output of our system
are normalized according
to OGC standards.
So you can see here
you have a WMS service.
So you can copy past
this URL and you
can put it plug-in in
your professional tool
and start doing your
work with your process,
with your [INAUDIBLE],
with all of that.
You don't have to mess
with our tool you just
are accessing to the data
through the cloud system.
So that's basically
the functionality.
So let's just-- we can
have a look to another area
and then we'll jump
to the complex.
So I think San Diego
was quite nice, too.
So let's move to San Diego.
OK.
So in San Diego here we are,
it's quite a desert area.
So it was all very nice, it's
always nice to look at it.
And you can see that the
pile of images is impressive.
I just removed the
background, but here.
OK.
So another point
with this system
is that there is, as
you may have noticed,
there is no ease showing
each image individually
at this point.
So that was--
What is, in this system
what is impressive
is there is no clouds.
So when you are shooting
the air from the sky using
the satellite it's a big
mess of cloud, in fact.
And our duty for
our customers is
to remove the cloud to get
the best images without cloud.
So when you pan
around and you take
each image there is
a minimum cloud here,
there is an image
with cloud, but we
don't care it's on the ocean.
OK.
So if we can go back
to the presentation.
OK, so now let's do
the artwork and let's
try to analyze what
is a complex workflow
and how to implement a complex
workflow of image processing
on the cloud.
So don't be scared, we will
not analyze that accurately,
just to provide you an example.
This should work.
OK.
OK, so it's up there and
it's sending somewhere
at the back side.
So what is important for us, and
I guess important for everybody
and for you, is that we should
not pay anything to Google
Cloud when there is no actions.
And that's what is happening
here in such a workflow.
So when we have no activity
we should have no compute.
So here this is the
beginning of the workflow.
And in this case,
it's a front end
and you have an operator or
the object of this workflow
is to have data database
with the freshest images
that show up in the
catalog or which
are available on the cloud free
data like Sentinel-2, MODIS,
and Landsat.
So let's start
updating the database.
And when it provided this
order it uploaded a message
on Pub/Sub queue.
And the Pub/Sub queue
is set up in a way
that it will awake processing
which is on app engine.
So that the way it starts.
And then this
processing it create
a compute, and the compute
will prepare the database,
will prepare the update
that is required.
So we'll look for all
the new images which
are available on this
area and interest,
prepare the parameters,
prepare all of it.
So then, hence, we
have a conclusion
that I have so many
images to analyze in order
to update a complex database.
And in most stuff our
analysis each image
has to be scanned one
after the other in order
to extract information.
And then this
information is crossed
with another information,
the other images, et cetera,
and then in order to
provide the final result.
So this engine is
putting for each image
in a Pb/Sub queue, a message
like process this image.
So here we are ending in
this BP, Pub/Sub queue.
We've a list of
hundreds and hundreds
of images to be processed.
So the same way
the Pub/Sub queue.
Wake up a tool which is
sitting on the engine.
And then this one through
the auto scaling that mature,
we'll describe later on.
For the auto scaling
system we will
create as many computes
as required in order
to do the process.
When it's done,
they are reporting
it's done updating the
database, and the next one,
the next process could start
and so forth up to the end.
So that's a specific workflow
for a remote sensing image
processing.
Most of the time a
remote sensing processing
could take from a few minutes
to an hour or two hours.
So it's not a standard
web processing.
It's some of the time
a long processing.
So then let me show you that.
So if we can switch
to the video again.
OK.
So here that's the
visualization of the workflow
that we have
introduced previously.
So as you can see, each line
corresponds to processing,
basically a compute.
So we saw that it has
been from zero compute.
It went up to as
many computes there
in order to do the first task.
So we have this tool which
is reporting on the activity.
So, by example, this process
is processing this image.
It took 747 seconds
to do the result, .
And is delivering the
result to the database
and when all of those are done
it can start a new process,
and the new process
is another process.
But when was telling you
that images from the sky
are quite a mess and
that's an example.
So here it's very cloudy you
cannot basically get anything
from this image.
But as you have many,
many, many images
you are able to
end with a result.
So step-by-step we scale up, we
scale down, we auto scale up.
And that's another
step where we have
been able to extract a piece
of information on this image,
on this spot.
This image is a MODIS
image, it's a NASA image.
But you can have NASA.
We have our own image
in this pile also.
And step-by-step it goes
through the process.
So then we have a kind
of summary of the result,
and we are ending
with the result.
And you can see, OK,
it was in France.
So it's kind of a joke.
But here from all of those
images which were very cloudy,
that's the statistic it's
about vegetation information.
That was the purpose
of this process,
which is updated at a certain
point of date in the year.
And the beauty of
the cloud system,
the auto scanning cloud
system which has been defined,
is here we run it for
the demo for France.
So it took some--
I mean sometimes I don't know
how many hours but maybe three
to four hours altogether.
But without any effort we
can run it on the IDF scale.
And so it will auto
scale at the right size
in order to make it happen.
And so that's, for
us, a key point
when we are developing
a new service.
Natively on the cloud,
the scalability capacities
are native.
And you can run it in
France, but you can--
In other words, when we are
getting the mosaic worldwide,
the mosaic I show you in One
Atlas, it takes us 48 hours
to use all the images which
are available worldwide.
And during we're
using 200 computes.
We could use more,
but for us I think
the mosaic done in two
days was acceptable.
So we kept the number
of computes at a 200.
OK.
So I'm done for my part.
So now Matthieu will
introduce to you
what has been developing
in Google and the way
in Airbus we use it.
MATTHIEU MAYRAN: Thanks.
So I'm going to start by
explaining a few Google Cloud
Platform concepts and to be able
to actually scale instances.
So the first
concept that we have
are actually regions and zones.
So we have data centers,
Google data centers,
in different locations
in the world,
and we call them regions.
So you can see
here some of them.
We are working on expanding
them during this year.
The region is usually there are
several regions in a continent,
and then within a region you
will have at least two zones
but even more to set up things
such as like high availability,
load overflowing, etc.
So in the zone, what you can
do is actually run some task,
but you need to
understand what sort
of task you need to
run and do these tasks
have right usage patterns.
So if you look at
use patterns there
are like two most common ones.
One is about its unpredictable.
So if you actually run,
let's say, a website.
So for example, when you
create a website to show images
of earth or if you run a website
for like ticketing system
you might actually
have a bunch of users
that actually you arrive at
the same time on the website,
and you need to scale
like in a second.
You might be like 100,000
users or something like that,
and you cannot
predict that, right?
So this is usually when
you need an auto scaler.
It's to actually be
able to scale based
on that unpredictable load.
The second one is a
bit more predictable.
It's when you're on a website,
let's say around the world,
and then the US wake
up, Europe and Asia
go to bed, something like that.
So if you look your over a
week a month or like a few days
you actually see
waves of traffic.
And this is predictable,
but it's also something
you need to be able to scale.
So in both cases you have to
be able to scale up and down.
The reason is if you
over provision you're
going to spend a lot of money
that you don't want to spend,
and if you under
provision, usually
you have to have
[INAUDIBLE] on your website
or your applications.
So if you don't
have enough machines
it's probably going to be
down for a lot of the users.
So I think we made the
point that we actually
need auto scaler,
but you also need
to understand what sort of
auto scaler you want to run.
So if we look at tasks, you
can have like short tasks,
for example serving of
websites or creating
thumbnails for images.
So usually that takes
about like milliseconds.
Yeah, usually milliseconds.
Or you can have
actually long processing
tasks such as transcoding
videos or rendering or actually
processing image
satellite, for example.
And those ones work differently.
And this is when you're
going to define, OK,
how do I go to scale these?
So this is what we're
going to look at,
but first we need to understand
the core component of running
a task, which is an instance.
This is the basics
of compute engine.
So with our instances
you can install, like,
operating systems,
start up screens.
You attach them to
a network firewall,
so a lot of the sessions here
are going to explain that.
But one of the specificity
of compute engine
is that you can actually
create custom VMs.
So if you're not happy with
the amount of CPU and memory
that we give you as a
set, you can actually
increase or decrease
some of them
to create your own machine.
And this is useful
because you can actually
fit to the performance
that you think you need,
or you can fit to the price
that your CFO thinks you need.
If you get it wrong though we
can actually give you an advice
as well.
So we look [INAUDIBLE]
all the time
using our own internal tools
like machine running, most
likely.
We can tell you, all oh, I
think here you might actually
want to downgrade
what you've set up
because you're spending
too much money based
on what you actually need.
Or we can also say,
look, you actually
should spend more
money and increase
what you're using to
improve the performance.
This is usually what we
call vertical scaling.
So you have an instance and
you just make it stronger
or you make it less strong.
But it's not always
like the best case,
because if you actually want
to process like gigabytes
of images, or if you want to
actually serve one million user
you can go with
one huge computer
but there's only so much CPU
and memory that you can actually
put in a computer
all in an instance.
So one useful thing
to do is actually
do always auto scaling,
which is multiplying
the amount of computers
that you're using,
which works for a
lot of use cases.
Doesn't work all the
time, sometimes you
need a massive computer.
But more and more
always auto scaling
is becoming the standard.
So to do that in
compute engine you use
managed instance group,
which is leveraging
an instance template,
[INAUDIBLE] holes here.
So the template you can
create it in different ways.
You can actually set
it up yourself saying,
like you did for
an instant, I want
that much CPU, that
much memory, and this
is going to be my template
that I'm going to reuse.
Or you can actually create
or reuse an instance
that you already had
and create an image
from it and from that
image creates a template.
And another solution we have
is actually to use containers.
So if you actually set
up containers and, like,
build it in Docker for example
and push it to our registry,
you can use that container
to create a template.
So a lot of different options
it depends on what you prefer
and how you want to work.
The thing is now you've got a
template so you can actually
create an instance group.
And that instance
group can be regional,
for example like
across different zones.
So if you need a
high availability,
or it can be on
one zone as well.
In that case it's two zones.
And it will be low balance.
So in front of it you would
be able to put a low balancer.
We're going to look at
that on the next slides.
Which help balancing
the load, thus the name.
And you're able to auto scale
it up and down depending
on your need, but
you would also be
able to do some rolling updates.
So if some days you're
like, OK, I need a new card
or I need like a stronger
instance or something,
you will be able to
automatically update
the instance group.
You would also be able
to auto healing instance.
So if one is actually
dying, you're
able to replace it automatically
by another one using
the template.
So let's go back to one of the
concept, the load balancer.
So we have different
load balancers
that we offer as a service.
We have like HTTP, HTTPS, TCB
proxy, SSL/TSL proxy, or UDP.
So different level on
the networking stack.
This one, for example,
is an HTTP load balancer,
which means like in that
case you will have an HTTP.
So you get one global
unique IP worldwide
that you can plug your
domain into, for example.
And behind the scene it will
connect to backend services
with a bunch of little steps.
And the backend services will
be able to actually route
a request to the right instance
in a right [INAUDIBLE] zone.
If you have different zone
or even in the right region
you can do session affinities
and a lot of things like that.
On the features of the
manage instance group,
so we saw some of them.
You have like
rolling update, which
will apply a template
to a number of instances
at the same time.
So you can define
how many instances,
but you're also
able to pause if you
need to double
check a few things,
and even roll back
if you decided
that you made a mistake.
We do that sometimes in Google.
Then you also have
the autohealing,
as we saw earlier, which is not
the same as the load balancer.
So it's leveraging
on the healthcheck,
and the healthcheck
appears in two things.
One is for the load balancer.
So a load balancer
uses that check.
OK, is that instance working?
If it is, it's fine I
can load traffic to it.
If not, I will just
use another one.
But the autohealing
use another one,
which is OK that
instance is not fine
and it's kind of not doing much.
Then I would just like
kill that instance
and replace it by another one.
And again it's using
the group template.
And the last one is the auto
scaler that you can put do it.
So you can actually
use different metrics.
It can be based on CPU, it can
be based on the load balancing
load, it can be based
on custom metrics
that you have in the monitoring.
So you can create your own.
It can be queue based, which
we are going to look later,
or it can get a combination
of some of them,
depending on what you need.
The auto scaler, just to explain
a little bit on how it works.
First, time wise
it will actually
look at how your instances
are behaving across like a one
minute sliding window.
So it will look at like across
the whole fleet of instance
in your instance group,
OK, how you doing CPU wise
or how you doing
metric wise basically.
And then every 10
seconds it would
be able to say, OK,
I need to scale up
or I need to scale
down based on that.
And usually it takes
about 30 seconds
to actually have a
VM up and running.
It's also cross zones,
so if you actually
have an instance group
that is regional,
you're going to be
able to create--
well, the auto scaler would be
able to create instances itself
and rebalance the work and
failover automatically.
And the last one is
money because everyone
has a CFO / so we
try to fit it as
much as we can to like
the minimum of instances
that you need.
We also enable you to
scale down to zero.
So if you don't need
to process anything
you don't need an instance.
And it's also leveraging
the permanent pricing
that we have in Google, which
means if you are running
an instance for
17 minutes you're
going to be charged for 17
minutes and not a full two
hours.
So I'm going to do
a little demo now,
hopefully it's going to work.
And it's showing how to
resize images on the fly.
So if you're in
[INAUDIBLE] tech,
for example or in
certain verticals,
you usually have like
maybe a big image somewhere
and you don't want to
create every single image
for every single phone,
every single tablet,
every single desktop,
and all that.
So sometimes it's actually
fast enough to actually
just resize it on the fly.
So I'm going to have my
image set up on the image
storage, Google Cloud Storage.
It's going to be about
a 5 megabyte image.
Then I already
pre-created a container,
which is in our registry
that you can access to
in Google Cloud Platform.
And the template we
leveraged that container
to create and to be leveraged
to create an instance group that
will be auto scaled.
And in front of
that instance group
we're going to put
a load balancer,
so we can actually
have one IP that is
accessible by all the clients.
So if we could switch
to the demo, please.
You better not have problems
like this when we are done.
Thanks.
So this is Cloud Storage.
It's a bookend, it's a folder.
Like, you put a bunch
of files in here,
and then I have one image
that is five megabytes
and this is pretty big
when you look at it.
So actually loading
these on like a tablet
would be quite hard
over 3G, right?
So what we want
to do is-- and you
can see here the file is
actually five megabytes.
So what we want
to do is actually
resize that on the fly.
So what I did is creating
an instance group,
and I played a little
bit with it yesterday
so you can see all
the spike here,
which is looking at the
number of instances in blue
and the CPU in green.
So currently I
have one instance.
And if I actually go
to that instance IP,
I'll show you after I did that.
I can actually
display that imagine
and it will be resized
on like a 450 width.
I don't know if you can
read that in that URL,
but this is basically
what it's doing.
So it's resizing the
picture on the fly,
and you saw that
it was quite fast.
So now what I'm just going to
do is actually load test this.
It's something
called [INAUDIBLE]
which can actually,
in that case,
call the URL 10 times per second
for a duration of five seconds.
And it's using this URL, which
doesn't have actually URL cell
IP, because this was
for one instance.
It has our load balancer IP.
Maybe I didn't do the
right one, let me check.
Should be this one.
Maybe I didn't set up correctly.
For some reason you don't set
up the load balancer correctly.
But we should still be able
to actually have the instance
group automatically scaling.
When I [INAUDIBLE].
Interesting.
OK, we might get
back to it later on.
OK.
So we can see here it
took a few seconds,
but you can see
that's based on this
it's actually
creating automatically
several instances.
And you can see in
real time you actually
have the number of
instances that is changing.
So we should see it
appearing in here based
on the CPU that is required.
And if more CPS's
are required, then I
would just launch
more instances.
If less CPU is
required it would just
kill them, as you can see
on what happened yesterday.
You can see now it's
using more actually,
because it realizes there was
a lot of flood really quickly.
So if we could go back,
sorry, the slides.
Thank you.
So that was the little demo.
It's actually using
several things.
The first one is Nginx, which
has actually an image filtering
that you can install.
So this is more or less
a default configuration
that I change myself.
I put that set up
into a container.
So this is a Dockerfile
to create a container,
and then you can build it and
apply it to two hours registry
and leverage that registry
to do several things.
The first one is to actually
create our instance template.
And you can see it
takes like a few lines.
So I just opened the
firewall for HTTP server,
which means we can actually
HTTP request the theme.
I used the micro
instance so it's small
so I can show you the scaling.
Then from that template, you
can create an instance group.
From that instance
group you say,
OK, I want to use
the template for it
and I want one
instance in there.
And I make it
regional, which means
I'm going to get automatically
actually higher availability
and fadeover.
And then that instance
group I will set up
an auto scaler, which is going
to be based on one instance
at a maximum of 20, because
you have four again.
And then I want
it to kick in when
I have like an overall
usage of my instance
group of 60% of CPU.
And then I give you
the cool down panel
of 90 second, which means like
for instances that I actually
started I'm just going
to say for a minute 30
they should then be taken
into consideration in my auto
scaling decisions.
So this is more or
less what I have
to do to create the
demo that I showed you.
So that works fine
because, as you saw,
it takes a millisecond
to resize that image.
But in our best use
case when you actually
have like huge
satellite images that
can take 10 minutes up to like
a few hours to get processed,
you actually don't want
to kill an instance
when it's almost done processing
an image after a few hours.
And you're like, OK,
yeah well actually we
don't need you anymore. and
you would have to reprocess.
So there's a few things
that you can put in place
to actually prevent that.
And one of them is to use
a Pub/Sub scale, Pub/Sub
based autoscaler.
Which in that case you will
have on the left hand side,
you will put an
image automatically
an App Engine or
cloud function is
going to look at, oh,
there's a new image.
Please change that
and process it.
So it will put that
in Cloud Pub-Sub.
And then a set of work that
you can see on the bottom
is going to be auto
scaled, and we'll just--
one worker will just pick
any match processing,
do whatever all they have
to do, and then save it
back to Cloud Storage.
To prevent instances to be
killed while they're actually
processing some things, so we--
I don't know if you can read,
but there is something written
CPU=1 and max backlog=x.
Let's say like three
images, so by combining
the two you actually scale
on the size of the Pub-Sub
and the queue, but
you prevent instances
that are working to get killed.
And this is like a
combination of those two
parameters in your auto scaler
prevent that from happening.
In the next few
slides we're going
to look at how Airbus
implemented this.
So they actually have a
couple of photo IDs as well.
And I wasn't supposed
to present that,
but Tomas, which you might
have seen on the first slide,
actually had a
baby last weekend.
So [INAUDIBLE].
And so you're stuck with me
for another three slides.
So the requirements:
were a lot of the things
that we already mentioned.
Airbus needed near real
time processing, which
means that they don't need
images to be actually treated
in real time but they need to
be treated as fast as possible.
So you don't want the
queue to basically wait
for like three hours because
you only have like two instances
there.
So you have to be able to
scale up and down based
on the size of the queue.
Another one is like
the jobs are actually
irregular across the year and
even like across the months,
across the dates.
Sometimes like you might
have to do like a mosaic that
is done yearly,
or you might have
to kick in like a
job for agriculture
but you don't really
know when it's happening.
So when nothing
thing is happening,
you obviously don't want to
have any instance running
because that might
last for a few months.
And when something is
happening you actually
want to be able to
start those instances.
So they needed
something to scale down
to zero, which we
actually mentioned before.
And they have long
running processes.
So as we said, like
processing an image
can take in between 10
minutes and a few hours.
This is why you don't want to
actually kill an instance that
is processing something.
Otherwise while the job is
going to get back into the queue
and then you're going to have
to wait for another few hours
to process that image.
And the last one is what type
of auto scaler do I need?
We mentioned that earlier.
So do I want an auto
scaler based on the CPU,
do I want an auto scaler
based on the custom metrics,
or do I actually want an auto
scaler based on something else?
So in that case
sometimes you have
instances that actually
you are using no CPU,
but are waiting on IOs.
So basically most of the
metrics that we had in standards
didn't work, so
you actually have
to base that on the amount of
images that are in the queue
to be able to process.
So those were all
the requirements,
and they came up with
a couple of ideas
or we come up with
a couple of ideas.
One of them was to actually
use a gatekeeper, which
is like a small
e-tolling instance
that we'll look at a queue.
See when there is a new
image that's coming,
see if that image should
actually be processed,
and put that image metadata
into a worker queue.
And the workers will look at it.
One is going to pick it up
and say, OK now, I'm working
and every instance
have metadata.
So they say I'm active, don't
do anything to me, please.
In this same time
the gatekeeper will
out in our data stall, which is
a free manage NoSQL Database.
We'll say, OK, I have like
an image being processed,
and this is how I keep track of
how many are being processed.
And the worker, when they
are done will basically
say, OK, that's it, I'm done.
If you need to
kill me please do.
I uploaded the image.
And the gatekeeper
will be able to look
at the ratio of how many
messages are in a queue
and how many
workers are leaving.
And then based on
that ratio will
be able to scale up all them.
So this was one solution.
The second solution that I set
up is a little bit simpler.
So you still have
that worker queue,
you still have an auto
scale number of workers.
And then there is like a
Cron is running every minute
and actually use monitoring
API from Pub/Sub to check, OK,
how many messages do I
have in the queue that
haven't been processed yet?
And then based on
that, and based
on the work that
are working, I'm
going to decide whether I
need to scale up or down.
So it's more like it's not
an event based auto scaler,
it's more like something that
happens every minute based
on the statistic that you
get from our monitoring tool.
So both are working,
they've been
implemented on
different projects
depending on their needs.
So it's really up
to you to see, OK,
do I need something
right away or do
I need something every minute.
It depends on your processes,
or you can also use the Pub/Sub
as we mentioned earlier.
This is an example
of what is going on.
So if we just look at
the top two screens
you can see on the left
how many jobs are needed,
so how many images
need to be processed.
And then you can
see on the right
how many instances
are actually working.
So total CPU, if you
see 8 in red percent,
means there are actually
eight instances working.
And you can see it's
actually matching,
like they're both green lines.
Well, not really lines but a
mountains actually matching.
So if you look at like 2:00 p.m.
you can see there is an
increase of how many jobs
I need to be processed.
And you can see in the meantime
like the CPU is working
and more instances are created.
And if you look at the end,
you don't need any image,
it's actually at zero.
And we also have zero instance
on the right over there.
And if you look at
the worker CPUs,
so you can look at per worker,
how's the CPU you look like?
The bottom line is our F1
micro, which was actually
managing the auto scaler.
So this is about it for like
explaining a few concept
for auto scaling.
Happy to answer a
question after a session.
But now we have a
couple of slides
to explain what Airbus
is going to do next,
and also how you can get
started if you're interested.
LAURENT GABET: OK.
Thanks so much Matthieu.
So for us, as a conclusion,
so first of all, when at last
our first services available,
so feel free to subscribe.
We have started
to develop our, we
call it Intelligent
Digital Platform.
So it's our basic system that
we keep growing, developing,
and which will enable us to
develop new services based
on analytic, to provide analytic
space on ML, [INAUDIBLE].
So that's what we
will continue to do.
And we have an ecosystem.
So we are new functions and
services where we are good at,
but we are not
good at everywhere.
So we are welcoming
partners that
would like to join
us to use our images,
or other images on our platform
or on another platform,
but accessing our data set,
our images through our APIs.
So you are welcome to join us.
And so now we are thinking
of putting at scale.
So we are currently uploading
our current satellite imagery,
but we have a 30 million image
satellites across since 1986,
and we are considering two to
upload them in our catalog.
And we are preparing
also ourself
to welcome the new satellites
which are being built now
in the near future.
So that's the conclusion for
me, and maybe some next steps
for Google side.
MATTHIEU MAYRAN: Thanks.
Yeah, I don't have
much to say about this,
you can read the
slide basically.
But if you want to get started,
please go to cloud.google.com.
It's a good start.
There is also a
session if you're
interested in learning more
about how to deploy update
instances and work with managed
instance group tomorrow,
I think.
Yeah, it's tomorrow.
And we have a little screening
with our architecture
on every floor on this floor.
And a fridge [INAUDIBLE]
architecture as well
with magnets.
So if you need to
talk to an architect,
if you have specific
architectural needs,
please come and meet us.
it's on the third
floor, and the treehouse
is one screen where you
can just touch and click
and you get a bunch of
architecturers out of it.
So there is always
one of us from my team
to answer your questions.
LAURENT GABET: Thanks.
OK, thanks.